[Music]
hello I'm festively andrew heaton and
you're watching mostly weekly new year's
traditions are a lot of fun from
igniting the family Christmas tree to
whacking the new year's ball or hiding
from newsy the new year's ghosts but I
have to say my favorite tradition is new
year's resolutions so I've come up with
several resolutions I'd like Congress to
do once they've sobered up read more
legislation listen I understand that it
takes a lot of time and effort to sit
down and read the bills you're about to
vote on they're boring and hardly any of
them have erotic pictures except for the
farm bill but it kind of makes sense to
actually read the stuff that's gonna
become law of course the main problem
isn't the lack of gripping erotica or
even lazy congressmen it's the
congressional leadership introduces a
bill to Congress and calls for a vote
before anyone's had time to read it
it's a neat trick to push legislation
through without giving anyone a chance
to consider if it's a bad idea or not
remember this but we have to pass the
bill so that you can find out what is in
it Kentucky Senator and libertarian
poodle Hybrid Rand Paul came up with a
pretty good Senate resolution that would
require one session day for every twenty
pages of a bill before it's eligible for
a vote seems like a good start war may
be form a congressional book club but
instead of books
it's bills and instead of a club it's a
job taxpayers pay you to do exercise
this bogey spring next year we're
shaping up to run a trillion dollar
deficit on top of a 20 trillion dollar
national debt if debt were calories but
I I don't know how calories work but I'm
pretty sure we'd all be dead that's
because Congress is cutting taxes but
it's not tackling the big issue spending
which is why Congress needs to lose some
weight budget weight and join a gym
specifically Jim Jordan that congressman
introduced a bill that would enforce
spending caps actually it was a bunch of
guys not all named Jim but whatever
joined Jim the federal government is
blowing through money don't believe me
here are a few examples of stuff we've
spent money on the federal government
gave thirty thousand dollars to help
make a production of doggy Hamlet which
is Shakespeare only with dogs it gave a
grant to expand the San Diego Trolley
service by 11 miles how much was that
grant only a billion dollar
and my favorite the National Science
Foundation paid four hundred and twenty
six thousand dollars for this in their
defense that shrimp was fat and all of
that is reasonable at least compared to
the corporate handouts bloated defense
appropriations runaway entitlement
spending and government malfeasance
billions of our taxpayer dollars go to
if Congress can tackle just some of the
gigantic spending splurges that happen
every year I will gladly sit through the
entirety of as you lick it get a hobby
instead of sexually harassing your staff
over the past twenty years Congress has
spent seventeen million dollars in
settlement money for sexual harassment
but even if we spent zero million
dollars it would be infinity million
dollars more than half of what we should
spend tell members of Congress avoid
future legal problems I've comprised
this list of alternate activities they
can do instead of sexually harassing
members of staff limit your screen time
of trumps Twitter feed why are you still
checking his Twitter feed his tweets
make less sense than the conspiratorial
rants from the homeless man outside my
laundromat good to hit sleazebags back
much better than seeing a psychiatrist
which I never have instead of wasting
time and mental effort go outside pick
up litter or read the bills you're
supposed to vote on or make a new friend
across the aisle Congress is even more
partisan than usual that ranked
tribalistic hatred isn't exactly helping
anybody
here's actual footage of House
Republicans squabbling with House
Democrats over a highway maintenance
bill well-intentioned
and intelligent people can disagree on
matters of substance there are good
people in both parties there are good
people who aren't in any political party
and there are six people in the green
party this year members of Congress
should get to know some of their
colleagues across the aisle and befriend
them maybe if politicians focused on our
shared humanity they could work together
and make that lazy shrimp lose weight so
happy new year everyone don't forget to
set your clocks back and who knows what
you can expect next year
[Applause]
for all the maintenance be forgotten
Nevermore to rain for all the
maintenance be forgot for auld lang syne